[Music]
[Music]
so I was separating the colors from the
whites but it felt too much like
segregation so I just put them all
together would you just admit that women
have it harder than men and our bet it's
all men never say die and I'ma show you
after I finished folding your fine
washables and making these fools person
open of it we ready babe hail to the
know my coin is hid
that's one small step for mankind and
one big slap across the face
little Chris what did I tell you about
coming in my house through the fridge
booyah make me come over there
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
it is a Colin Kapernick tur ain't nobody
got it harder than brothers hashtag me
too well sisters are the backbone of
this country and we're reclaiming our
time the pigs did it to me cops beat you
what Oh No
there's that I'm highly allergic to port
next time off forgive me I am so bad
with names you can call us by Wakanda
names
team Jala teach oh yeah
[Music]
now forgive me
I am so bad with names but it's Yolanda
kavaja and Kevin or you can call us by
our Condor needs deep chana teach oh
yeah to choose to live your white ass in
another place put on the grease be a
part of these please
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
next time or what Percy was a good man
he lost his life to Isis
that's what is asking for cheating on me
Isis don't play
[Music]
my boy Percy was a good man he lost his
life to Isis
that's what is asking for cheating on me
Isis don't play Percy never returned my
Keith Sweat album so he's been dead to
me somebody's a repast so real a little
Chris what did I tell you about coming
in my house - Percy's casket
[Laughter]
next time or I'm gonna watch my favorite
movie lean on me
dad disrespect God in this house young
lady hey cabeza hey about to watch
football or as I call it let daddy eat
whatever he want and get Diabetes Day
the NFL's canceled
stay woke hey Alexa play r.kelly can't
canceled stay woke Kevin I'm gonna watch
my favorite movie lean on me
you smoked crack don't you Morgan don't
disrespect God in this house young lady
go to your room expeditiously
oh these kids
[Music]
you